[Music]
thank you
let's begin on American politics for the
cover of the magazine this week I've
written a piece about the looming or
emerging battle between Ron DeSantis and
Donald Trump for the Republican
nomination for the presidential election
next year
Donald Trump spoke at CPAC last weekend
where he tried to Rally the conservative
base in his favor and I think it's fair
to say that he's had a good few weeks
politically he's gaining in the polls
and is emerging once more as the
favorite to win the nomination he does
face a significant challenge however in
the form of Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis who has not officially declared
as a presidential candidate but
everybody knows he's running so who is
going to win I'm joined Now by Andrew
Coburn who is Washington editor of
Harper's magazine as well as Daniel Lee
Thompson who is a scholar and strategist
Andrew I'll start with you uh you wrote
what I think is the best piece I've read
about Rhonda centers called swamp landia
in Harper's magazine
um I wonder if you might start by
telling us a little bit about your
understanding of Rhonda santis and how
it differs from what perhaps we've heard
here in Britain and internationally
well the general sort of take on Rhonda
Santos says
put out in the media is that you know
that he's a very ideological sort of
politician and that he you know
campaigns against woke he was so
outraged by Disney's sort of wokous
liberal positions that he went after
them that he uh you know that he's
generalist you know a Plucky fighter in
the culture wars
um and that's been you know that's the
sort of Main
trust the sort of swear point of his uh
of his campaign and I point out that
actually what he is is the most
distinguishing feature of Ron is that
he's a sort of corporate Toady
um that he's been uh ever since well
certainly ever since he started
campaigning for governor in uh in 2018
that you know he's left no stone
unturned or no uh no dinner unturned in
order to um you know shake them down for
really enormous sums of money which has
been amazingly successful at I mean
that's he's really peeled away the uh
main sort of
big Republican big donor base and he's
been very assiduous at that both in
Florida itself with rather I think
unfortunate results for Floridians but
also for the uh you know across the
country where they all all the
billionaires thrilled with his message
certainly got a lot of money behind him
and the fox group of Murdoch Empire also
seems to be supporting him quite a lot
um do you think in recent weeks uh after
the midterms there was a lot of Ron
DeSantis hype the New York Post called
him Ron the future uh
yeah do you think that
um that has faded slightly and recently
certainly the polls suggest Trump is
pulling ahead again among Republican
primary voters do you think Asda
santis's campaign comes into contact
with reality it may start to
disintegrate
yes I think so I mean it's been um you
know certainly the Trump
faction have been or a trump Camp have
been
saying well so I think with some justice
and accuracy that you know once DeSantis
starts to sort of go across the country
and have to talk to Ordinary People
which he doesn't like doing very much so
he doesn't like people I don't think
um
um unless they're sort of proper and
huge checks uh that you know that'll you
know people will sense that
um you know those are so curiously I
mean I compared him in the piece to
Richard Nixon and you know that I you
know they're both both politicians who
didn't like very people very much but
had to pretend they did
um but that sort of comes through you
know whereas Trump you know Trump is
sort of is um
uh uh is a
he has this sort of extra sort of
comedic twist to him he uh
he sort of almost laughs at himself
there's always a slightly
tongue-in-cheek sort of uh
um
uh aspect of trump which I uh I think
people people like and you know can you
imagine Ron DeSantis trying to do a
dress a trump rally you know that sort
of Mega crowd I mean he'd pull you know
he'd be completely wouldn't so I think
um I'm not surprised that the uh
DeSantis
um
auras fading a bit
Danielle uh you wrote a very
entertaining piece
um about The Vibes at CPAC which is the
conservative political action conference
um uh Trump addressed it last week and
for you it fell quite flat despite a lot
of the talk about Trump's success in the
polls and his rallying of the
conservative base in recent weeks
yes
um you know the conservative political
action conference has been a flagship
event for conservatism since 1974 and I
remember going there in the years after
Trump just got elected and there was
energy in the air there was that sort of
spirit some sort of transcendent quality
that this was something new he was
offering something different that
expanded Beyond just the usual culture
award dribble of the Republican party
and this year uh as I said in the piece
The Vibes were off uh I described Vibes
as something like a sense of
authenticity and shared spirit and
everyone there from the journalist to
the hardcore Maga types to people who
worked uh you know who have spoken at
CPAC for years felt that something was
off I would say that Trump was just
about the only person who had a little
bit of Verve in the room and honestly I
think it was because he still has a bit
of a nationalist populist appeal in his
two-hour address the majority of what he
spoke about was
um you know free trade Fanatics and
anti-military intervention and also just
taking on the establishment that I
counted in my recordings he had about 30
seconds dedicated to uh like transgender
insanity and CRT but that is very
different from DeSantis who is something
of a culture War chat GPT of sorts
do you think uh the reason the
atmosphere was perhaps a little bit flat
is that Trump conservatism or trumpism
uh has failed it seems at the ballot
three times running now in 2018 in the
midterms 2020 in the presidential
election
and 2022 although it didn't exactly fail
but but a lot of high-profile Trump
candidates
um failed do you think there's a sense
that then they're on the losing side now
you know it's really hard when you make
a career as a winner as a as in the
image of luxury and success to confront
the fact that you failed and it's also
really hard to claim Underdog status
when you've been president of the United
States
that only kind of works so long and on
top of that Trump's style his sort of
bombastic
aggressive uh style which works for him
because he's been doing that on
television in the press for 30 years or
more uh when other people try to copy it
his surrogates and those around him it
continues to fall flat and it seems
inauthentic so it doesn't have the Vibes
so to speak and so in some ways by
trying to copy Trump as CPAC has and
failing to capture the authenticity you
kind of fail to capture what is
interesting about Trump which is a more
Transcendent appeal
did you uh speak to the people there at
CPAC about DeSantis he wasn't there
obviously um it probably would have been
pretty stupid for him to go because he
would have lost the straw pole uh which
showed DeSantis with a huge lead among
the CPAC delegates yes I did speak to
them you know it was firmly Trump Maga
territory a lot of Bannon War Room fans
uh mostly whom are older women I found
uh were at CPAC and I spoke to them the
people who were there for the first time
of course were excited about it because
they were with like-minded people but
the folks who were Veterans of CPAC who
have been there for years who know what
it was like in 2017 or 2018 or even
before that in the Tea Party days uh
they felt something was flat there just
simply weren't as many people Fox News
wasn't there Charlie Kirk's Turning
Point USA wasn't there so the sort of
college Republican sect wasn't there it
felt a little bit empty quite frankly
and not as energetic Andrew do you think
uh we may be in danger of missing uh
desantis's appeal because uh even though
you know at CPAC and among conservative
actress he doesn't have that that trumpy
uh Pizzazz uh he has still got according
to polls about 30 percent of the
Republican vote and he hasn't even
officially started running yet I think
Nate Cohn at the New York Times uh has
calculated that he's doing better in
early polls than Reagan John McCain
Barack Obama or Joe Biden were at a
similar stage
um when you look at the broader
Republican electorate does he have more
of a hold on them
well he'll certainly get a Big Slice of
them I mean but the you know we're
talking about
you know who will get the biggest slice
I I still firmly believe it'll be Trump
especially when DeSantis you know has to
cope with you know the the Nikki Haley's
of this world or
whoever else jumps in I mean it's not
clear if there's going to be many of
them but when a sort of crowded field
um I think it would be better for Trump
if it's not a crowded field actually if
it's just him versus DeSantis if you
imagine a debate stage with just the two
of them then Trump can on unleash his
full
um rhetorical vehemence
um on the santis if there's a whole
bunch of them there they're all sort of
nibbling at trump it might it might go
the other way I I mean I still I mean I
I've I can't somehow I can't see
DeSantis really eating into the mega
vote
um too much I mean he'll get some of
them and he'll certainly get all those
you know or get a lot of those Suburban
College Republicans or whatever who
uh who like trumpism without Trump which
is what you know in a lot of ways and
get with DeSantis and I think they they
may well detect you know there's a very
slithery
aspect of DeSantis which I think sort of
comes through
um
so you know we're talking about who gets
the nomination in the end my money is
still on Trump and of course you know
the Democrats are hoping fervently it's
Trump
um and they don't like the idea of
DeSantis at all
um you know Trump as a you know as I as
I as I wrote he he's going to very much
run on the sort of nationalist
anti-war you know he would have settled
the Ukraine war within hours he will
settle over the Ukraine war within ours
and DeSantis has edged towards that he's
signed on to the no black no blank check
for Ukraine uh so stream which is sort
of the halfway house for Republicans
um but um you know DeSantis he'll run
you know he's got anti-woke he you know
his big thing was sort of anti-vaxxer
and you know I'm the one who kept
Florida open
um you know I defied pouchy and all that
um you know actually he didn't for quite
a while wasn't until he realized and
this is you know he is very clever he he
he he sensed that the Maga crowd didn't
you know were recoiled from the mandates
recoiled from the mandatory vaccines
were recoiled from lockdowns and masks
and all that but you know by
I think even now and certainly by next
year I think all the sort of memories of
that will have faded so it won't be
quite a as potent as selling point as he
might have hoped Daniel Ukraine is
already emerging as a major talking
point uh in the Republican primary
um do you think that Donald Trump's kind
of Peace suit piece through strength
message that he he would be able to
solve it in a day by just talking to
Vladimir Putin do you think that has cut
through to use the slightly disgusting
phrase
possibly I think that Trump has always
tried to appeal to an imagined Middle
America so he visited East Palestine in
Ohio if you recall where the train
derailment occurred and so there's this
sort of blue-collar cultural uh culture
that he tries to appeal to and you have
to remember and as Steve Bannon points
out on his podcast war room all the time
that's where the boys who go to fight
the wars are from and so Trump is trying
to appeal to that crowd like we don't
want another Iraq and Afghanistan
situation we don't want another George
Bush situation we want to get out of it
so he really tries to position himself
as an outsider on that issue and what he
said at his speech in CPAC was I didn't
get us involved in more Wars I got us
out of them and so that's his commitment
that he's tried to make and position
help himself differently from people
like DeSantis who has already received
like a passive endorsement from Jeb Bush
on Fox so I think that that's something
that we really have to look out for it's
hugely critical and Americans generally
speaking after having been in some ways
red pilled by those Wars on terrorism
they don't want it anymore they don't
want another mass mass War
let's go back to DeSantis and Vibes
Danielle I think
is it possible I did a piece on it this
week and I was thinking about this is it
possible that the scientists can create
his own Vibe because he is uh Andrew
compared him to Nixon he is uh he does
have this professional very serious uh
atmosphere about him he does campaign
quite belligerently against woke which
is obviously a quite an emotive issue
um do you think he can create his own
Vibe which is uh different enough to
trumpism to inspire some optimism
so I think that DeSantis really relies
on this uh culture War division which is
honestly a classic tactic of the
Republican party it's a sort of
diversion away from maybe more systemic
change around military interventionism
or trade or tax which Trump uh tried to
take on and that was his appeal so
DeSantis I think it I I think it was one
of you who said he sort of cringe
sometimes and DeSantis will have to kind
of own his cringe if he's going to have
something vibey or authentic so on the
one hand he can be pretty belligerent
with the Press but that's something he
almost learned from Trump and so is he
going to be able to find his own
authenticity in his wankish nerdiness as
opposed to trying to copy what is
essentially just a a an opposition to
the Press which became popularized in
Trump but honestly has its roots in
generations and Decades of conservatism
and alternative media in conservatism so
we'll see if he can make his own
authentic cringe
Andrew finally
um DeSantis is uh economically
conservative economically right-wing if
you like
um and uh Trump is not and uh this week
he's been hitting DeSantis pretty hard
on the point that he will protect uh
Social Security and Medicare
um Santa's came out very quickly and
said so would he
um but his voting record suggests
otherwise and that uh means that Trump
is on the side of a Republican party
that is increasingly working class
increasingly left-wing it seems in its
uh economic ideas uh do you think that's
the sensitive biggest problems he's not
really left-wing enough for the new
Republican Party
well that's an attractive thought
um you know I just want to say something
about the sentence you know they've got
this huge 20-point Victory and uh in the
election
um
in 22 but he you know he was up
it would have been hard for him to lose
I mean because there were Democrats put
up this pathetic character of Charlie
Crist the Democratic party in Florida is
essentially sort of Fallen apart the
national Democrats had given up on that
didn't give them any money
um the Santa's had finally come around
to this popular sort of anti-lockdown
position which was very popular in in
Florida so although you know he carries
the aura of sort of triumphant success
with him
um I'm not so sure that's going to sort
of
you know that that he's really that
brilliant and successful a politician
um you know he didn't he scraped home uh
in his first election
um with the help of trump which Trump
will certainly not let him forget
um he you know I think I think once
we're into the Republican primaries
um
I think this sort of populist you know
his attempt to be a populist well Paul
pretty flat especially one if Trump
starts chanting the names of all the
sort of billionaires who've given him
money and you know and actually Trump
might have a have a go Trump trump the
Communists might have a go and sort of
talking about the incredible favors
DeSantis has done for insurance
companies for you know landlord
companies for all the rest in in Florida
so um I think it could be I guess it
will certainly be a fun race I'm looking
forward to it
I think it will be fun uh Daniel I
finally I'd actually like to ask you one
more question and I'm sorry if this is
sexist because I'm asking because you're
a woman but there's been a lot of talk
about Casey uh DeSantis uh Rhonda Santos
wife uh and that she is apparently the
the sort of driving force the brains
behind the operation uh and has actually
pushed at Ron DeSantis into running uh
because he's actually a bit reluctant do
you have a sense of her and whether she
might have her own vibes
well I know that uh the first lady of
Florida definitely has a style that is
very distinct I haven't seen someone
wear Opera gloves to a speech in a very
long time she definitely has a kind of
Jackie O energy which you know if you
spend any time in CPAC or among certain
sects of conservatism there is a sort of
uh you know uh performative femininity
that happens in a way uh it definitely
is fun to dress up for CPAC I'll say
that
um but I would say that she definitely
has ambition she's a former television
personality herself and so that would
definitely help him in trying to seem
more authentic or speaking to the kind
of local television news tabloid style
that Americans are really familiar with
that they wake up to every day on local
news so possibly you know her presence
and her energy and her ability to
connect to that to audiences and I mean
that by television audiences might
actually help uh Ron in the long run
it's certainly going to be very
interesting Danielle and Andrew thank
you very much indeed for joining us
[Music]